a couple of items for all of you this
afternoon
today the president is meeting with
business leaders and ceos that have
instituted vaccine requirements or are
working to implement the new
requirements these leaders represent a
diverse range of sectors from businesses
large and small including university
systems tourism retail tech and health
care the president will highlight their
leadership putting into place strong
covet 19 requirements that help keep
workers safe and that are already
showing results with an increase in
vaccinations to provide a few examples
when tyson's foods announced its
requirement only 45 percent of its
workforce had gotten a shot in less than
a month it increased to 72 percent after
united airlines announced its vaccine
requirement the vaccine rate for
employees went from 59 to 79 in less
than a month and in washington state the
weekly vaccination rate jumped 34 after
the governor announced requirements for
state workers this event will underscore
these requirements will help sustain our
economic recovery and level the playing
field for businesses across the country
i also wanted to note that during this
critical period of negotiations on the
build back better agenda the vice
president will make her first trip to
the treasury department since taking
office to hold an event with treasury
secretary janet yellen and make the case
for the biden harris administration's
proposed investments in child care that
will benefit women children and working
families they will announce the release
of a major new treasury department
report on the economics of child care
and the report confirms child care
remains too expensive and out of reach
and that our child care industry is in
need of significant public investment
to bring down the cost for working
families
last piece i wanted to note is today the
families of more than 60 million
children nearly 90 percent of american
kids will receive the third monthly
payment of the child tax credit this is
one of the most significant tax cuts for
working families in history and is
already helping americans meet the cost
of raising children using this
additional money to help pay for
groceries back to school clothes braces
and so many other expenses most of the
families will again see child ctc in
their bank account today with a payment
of 250 to 300 dollars for each child
studies have shown that it will boost
consumer spending uh jobs and has also
has already led to a major fall in
hunger and child poverty 97 percent of
the children receiving this tax relief
are in working families and we've
already seen reports of strong support
for the tax cuts for families across the
board including from independence and 41
percent of those who identify as
republicans and we're working of course
to get it extended for even longer
jonathan why don't you kick us off
thanks jeff uh a new book reports that
near the end of the trump presidency
chairman milly had two conversations
with his chinese counterpart promising
the countries would not go to war and
that he would give an early warning that
something were to happen in a statement
just minutes ago chairman millie did not
dispute this account
on this
does the president feel these calls were
appropriate does he have confidence in
the chairman and some republican
senators have called for chairman lily
to be dismissed is he going to keep his
job
well i saw the statement of course that
the department of defense i should say
the joint chief spokesperson uh just
released
released minutes ago i'm not going to
add more speak to anonymous unconfirmed
reports about conversations with limited
context from here
but what i can assure you all of is that
the president knows general milley he
has been chairman of the joint chiefs
for almost eight months of his
presidency they've worked side by side
through a range of international events
and the president has complete
confidence in his leadership his
patriotism and his fidelity to our
constitution since you gave me the
opportunity i just wanted to add i think
it's important to consider some of the
context a key context of this period and
time of time in history that we're
discussing and is outlined or covered in
portions of
this book
the outgoing president of the united
states during this period of time
fermented unrest leading to an
insurrection and an attack on our
nation's capital on january 6 which
we've all you all have covered
extensively of course one of the darkest
days in our nation's
history beyond reports in this book
there's been widespread reporting and
commentary from members of his own
cabinet the former president's cabinet i
should say including high-ranking
national security officials questioning
the former president's stability his
behavior and his suitability to oversee
the national security of the united
states so those are important questions
that need to be discussed as well i want
to follow this the president believe
that john milley should testify before
congress about his actions during that
time
look i think we
the president has been clear with his
administration and members of his
cabinet national security team that
we'll continue to work with congress and
uh cooperate with them uh as appropriate
uh in meeting their needs we've done
that from the beginning of the
administration i would defer to the
department of defense and the joint
chiefs for further uh decisions i'll
hand off so you can just give a comment
on the what seems to be the escalation
of tensions between north and south
korea sure
uh well i would first note that um the
state department and indo-pacom have
both put out statements as well that i
would point you all to if you haven't
seen them
i would note that in indo-pacom's
statement they said they of course are
aware of the missile launch as are we
they've also also stated that they have
a set this set assess that this event
does not pose an immediate threat to us
personnel or territory or to our allies
the initial launch highlights the
destabilizing impact of the uh dpr dprk
illicit weapons program uh so i would
point you to those note those i don't
think we have additional commentary from
here at this point go ahead thanks jen
i'm following up on jonathan's comments
questions here does the president have
any concerns that uh general milly
perhaps worked outside of the chain of
command at all
again i think why it was important for
me to convey what i did is that the
president has worked
side by side with chairman milley for
almost eight months as the chairman of
the joint chiefs his experience with him
has been that he is a patriot he is
somebody who is uh is has fidelity to
the constitution and he has confidence
in his leadership and the role he has
played in his experience with him i
can't speak to anonymous unconfirmed
reports about prior conversations during
the last administration
former president trump called these
actions insubordinate and treasonous you
must respond directly to that name one
more topic i don't think i have any
further response to the former president
other than to reiterate the context of
this moment in time what everybody's
talking about here and what we're
reporting on just quickly on
uh has publicly said that he would
support a vaccine mandate for air travel
is that something the white house is
actively considering
well i know that jeff zion spoke to this
just a little while ago or i should say
earlier this morning
and what he conveyed is that of course
as i stated i should say back in august
we have been discussing and looking at
ways to provide consistency to provide
clarity
and steps that will ensure
air travel international air travel i
think you're asking about here but
ensure it's done in an equitable way and
the current rules have been quite
confusing are the rules that have been
in place for some time
but that's not an indication of a new
policy that's forthcoming go ahead
what are the lessons that the white
house draws from the outcome of the
california recall election in terms of
mandates
and
uh vaccines and medicaid
sure
well
obviously we
would note since you gave me out the
training i'll say there's a statement
coming from the president shortly he has
not yet spoken with governor newsom but
i expect he will either later today or
sometime soon just just in case that was
another question uh but of course this
was a resounding victory for governor
newsom but also for a science-based
approach to fighting the pandemic for
vaccines for testing for steps that will
protect uh more people and save more
lives and there's extensive data from
last night that shows that californians
were overwhelmingly in favor of a leader
who is willing to take strong steps to
defeat covid and get the economy up and
running governor newsom has been one of
the leading governors in the nation
protecting his people and vaccinating
his state and in our view this was a
resounding uh support of victory and
victory for that if i could ask a
follow-up on it doesn't matter how much
confidence does the president have
that the drone strikes in afghanistan
that killed isis militants
how much confidence in which aspect of
it how much confidence does he have that
the drone strikes killed the targets
that were intended to be
isis
fighters as opposed to
innocent victims on the street and does
he take responsibility
if
if the innocent victims were killed well
first there is an investigation that's
ongoing as there always is um in any
event of drone strikes that could have
impacted instant civilians and the
united states takes incredibly seriously
uh our role in preventing civilian uh
casualties whenever we possibly can so
i'm gonna let that play out the
president also takes that responsibility
uh incredibly seriously we'll let that
conclude and then i'm sure we'll have
more to say but he doesn't know the
answer i guess right well that's why
there's an investigation to determine uh
what happened and uh and make some
conclusions
i wanted to ask first about uh
filibuster you said last month that
there was no change in the president's
viewpoint on that uh does that remain
the case and is it a topic that is being
discussed with senators cinema and
manchin today the senator cinema and
mansion are here to discuss the build
back better agenda and this path forward
and
i know one of the meetings was happening
one of them is happening later this
afternoon the president certainly
believes there'll be ongoing discussions
not that there's necessarily going to be
a conclusion out of those today but that
was the primary focus and purpose of
these meetings is there a change as far
as the president's opinion on the
filibuster
there right now our goal uh has been on
moving voting rights legislation forward
the senate has obviously been working
through it there's been some
announcements made about progress on
compromise agreements that's a positive
step uh but there hasn't been any
additional change and no change on the
president's opinion as far as
filibusters correct okay and then on a
different subject on booster shots there
was uh fda staff that said today that um
it's not clear at this point whether
booster shots are
useful for the general public
you have a plan to start
giving those out on september 20th is
that date still on and
uh
do you need to wait uh more in order to
get more of a scientific consensus
behind that policy
well first i would say on on august 18th
so almost a month ago
after weeks of discussion eight of the
department of health and human services
top doctors released a statement saying
they had determined boosters would be
needed and that we have a plan to begin
a booster program starting the week of
september 20th subject to an independent
evaluation from the fda and acip that
continues to be the case uh
right now what we're looking at is that
today the fda provided more data that
will be analyzed through independent and
rigorous scientific process a formal
meeting is also happening of the
vaccines and related biological products
advisory committee that will take place
on friday and next week um the acip is
planning to meet and based on their
recommendation we're prepared to
operationalize so those are the steps
that will be occurring nothing has
changed as it relates to the eight top
doctors who put out that statement
almost a month ago there was always
going to be a process that process is
proceeding so even if there's no
consensus you will be moving forward
with the [ __ ] no the the
where it is subject to an independent
evaluation from fda and acip that was
what we said in august that is what
continues to be the case today so that
process is playing out now
go ahead thank you um just to put a
finer point on it because you brought up
the context a couple of times does
president biden believe that general
milley may have been acting in the
national interest by circumventing
a former president who he feared was
acting erratically
well it's the obligation of every
chairman of the joint chiefs to follow
constitutional orders to prevent
unlawful military action that's what the
president believes
but it's also important to understand
the context of when this reporting was
happening during and the fact that the
former president was
fomenting an insurrection and there was
broad concern from a range of members of
his national security team about his
behavior and fitness for office uh and i
know you all know and i have reported on
that context but that is missing a
little bit as people are discussing that
so you think general milling may have
been acting patriotically by having
these conversations again i'm not going
to give further analysis other than to
say that the president believes he's
patriotic um that he is his fidelity to
our constitution is unquestionable and
he has complete confidence president had
a fuller conversation with general
milley about all this since the books
details were publicized yesterday i
don't have any other further
conversations to read out go ahead
even if the president believes that the
intentions and the patriotism of general
milly were in line with his own values
is there a point where criticism
makes general milly unable to continue
in this role
because it is a new administration it's
a new day and there are some questions
about if he exceeded his authority well
again uh the president uh has complete
confidence in his leadership his
patriotism and his fidelity to our
constitution i can't speak to the former
president's
experience with him or the former
president's views of him but this
president this current president who
follows the constitution who's not
fomenting an insurrection who follows
the rule of law has complete confidence
in chairman milley and him serving
continuing to serve in his role and even
as republicans may criticize and have
questions about his suitability to
continue
would that be a factor that president
biden would consider
separate from his judgment about how he
conducted himself before
i don't think the president is looking
for the guidance of members of congress
who stood by while the their the
president of their par the president of
the united states and the leader of
their party fermented an insurrection
and many of them were silent
john thank you the larry nassar
situation and the testimony with
congress you know simone biles delivered
powerful testimony saying enough is
enough and i didn't hear you address it
at the top so if you could say and
elaborate what is the president's
position on the larry nassar situation
and does he have a reaction to what to
what simone vile said to congress today
well i would say her testimony was
incredibly powerful ali reismans was
incredibly powerful all of these women
who were brave and courageous and came
forward and spoke about
the abuse of a monstrous human being
that they lived through
as gymnasts as some of the nation's top
athletes that's courageous that's brave
they're playing a role in preventing
this from ever happening again i would
note that also discussed was of course
the doj's inspector general report and
the testimony we heard
today was also about that and the
department of justice has said that the
fbi is promptly
taking the steps outlined in the report
to ensure that this can never happen
again which certainly the president
supports that and then a follow-up one
more for boosters i asked the president
on the south lawn yesterday if he would
be willing to take that booster dose you
said at the podium that he would after
you know some time after the
recommendations but he didn't elaborate
is the president going to take the
booster dose
yes once it's approved through the
process that i just outlined go ahead
thanks jen i know you've spoken about
millie quite a bit but what is the
president's response to this criticism
that the chairman of the joint chiefs
exceeded his authority usurped uh
civilian authority and
does there exist any fear that that
could happen to any administration
including this administration
well again this is why i provided the
context right because what we're talking
about here one let me just restate again
that there are a range of reports in
this book anonymous unconfirmed i
realized that the department of defense
or i should say the joint staff
spokesperson put out a statement if you
look at that statement that is really
about what the normal channels of
communication are which are important to
understand as well broadly speaking
beyond this book the chairman of the
joint chiefs any chairman of the joint
chiefs has channels to communicate with
china and russia that those are meant to
increase confidence those are meant to
prevent
and deter any um uh any action that
would be um that would be unintended um
and that is a good thing uh because
obviously we want to prevent nuclear war
so what i can speak to though is the
president's view of of chairman milley
and obviously chairman millie has been
by his side for almost eight months uh
the president's experience with him is
that he is a man of honor uh he is a man
whose uh the president's confident in
his leadership his patriotism his
fidelity to the con constitution i can't
speak to and i'm not going to speak to
anonymous unconfirmed out of context
reports from the last administration on
the blinking hearings i know the
secretary of defense was invited to the
hearings yesterday on the hill but did
not appear and democrats are considering
exercising subpoena power or hinting at
that
would the president support secretary
austin appearing before congress would
you encourage it he is appearing before
congress at the end of the month
and he's already agreed to that and then
on coveted boosters um there's been so
much reporting about yeah
the fda and the cdc in this battle uh
reports this battle between
moving forward with this timeline and
getting the regulators and the
scientists to sign off on it
what is the president's response to
criticism that politics might have
played a role in the september 20th
timeline
well first it was a statement that was
put out by eight of the nation's top
doctors and public health officials it
wasn't a statement put out by the white
house
and it was uh done in response to data
that was made available about the waning
effectiveness of vaccines and it was
their responsibility or they felt it was
their responsibility at the time to make
their recommendations publicly available
it is still a process that needs to be
seen through and that process is
undergoing is underway i should say
right now and we of course respect that
process and we'll wait for that process
to conclude uh oh go ahead justin
go ahead thank you just to follow up on
these questions about general miller
yeah how much agency does the president
believe that those in the comm in the
chain of command should have when it
comes to assessing whether an order is
constitutional you know
what if
someone who's serving this president
feels that uh there's an order or a
policy that he uses contrary uh contra
contravening the constitution how much
agency does this president give to those
beneath him in the line of chain of
command well beyond this president any
pr or any president it's the obligation
of every chairman of the joint chiefs to
follow constitutional orders to prevent
unlawful military action this president
has no intention of fomenting unrest or
an insurrection he has no intention uh
of of obviously moving forward or
recommending unlawful military action uh
he has no intention of uh of working in
a way that is outside of uh what his
national security team what his military
commanders are aligned with him i mean
obviously they're going to give him a
range of recommendations but you know he
has no intention of of of working
outside of
of what is legally allowable so i don't
think that's going to be an issue for
this president let me ask you follow-up
to the vaccine mandate question what's
the why you last week you were asked
about you know the obligation that
employers have and you suggested that
large employers have the ability to pay
for
certain things what's the advice the
white house would give to employers that
might find it difficult to find the
people to do certain things what if
particularly in blue collar industries
what if people say you know what i don't
need the vaccine i don't want the
vaccine what should an employer do
should an employer fire his workers and
then what well there's a process of osha
is going through the process of
determining the regulations and
requirements here to give businesses and
employers all these clear guidelines
which are all good questions that are
being asked and hopefully we'll have
more on that in the coming weeks
i would say that some of the industries
and business leaders who will be here
today represent a diversity of
industries with a diversity of
workforces and what we've seen of the
examples to date um is that uh what
we've is that there's been an increase
in vaccinations that that has actually
been something that has been
economically advantageous to a number of
businesses and industries around the
country and so that's not uh we're
looking at the models of the past as
models of what can happen in the future
but there are good questions about what
these requirements will look like and
that's what osha is working on now go
ahead
thanks tim
you said you don't want to respond to
unconfirmed out of context reporting but
you've also given a really ringing
endorsement to general milly so i guess
my question is is it fair to say that
the president feels he knows enough
about
what general milly did or didn't do at
the end of the last administration or
does he want to know more
he knows general milley and he's worked
beside him for the last nearly eight
months uh and that's what gives the
president confidence in him this is
finished as far as he's concerned in
other words there's nothing more to
investigate
well we'll we'll leave it to congress
and others to ask questions they want to
ask and obviously the department of
defense the joint chiefs uh and others
will speak to that but i'm just speaking
to where the president stands go ahead
jen politico has a report that there'd
be an agreement coming with australia
and the uk um there's a line there that
could involve nuclear capability as well
is there a situation in which the u.s
would ship bomb-grade fuel to a
non-nuclear weapon state
i've seen the reports out there and i
know there's been a call this morning to
give people a preview of what's coming
later and we're going to wait for any
announcement to be made more officially
later this evening just on the question
of the situation if the u.s would is
there a situation where the u.s would
ship that bomb great fuel again uh the
parameters of this agreement and the
announcements later today we'll leave it
to that announcement to be made i know
there was a briefing this morning as
well any update on the measles outbreak
that caused the suspension of flights of
afghan allies to the us let me let me
give you i'm not
i don't know how much you know so well
but i'll tell you what i know and then
we'll see um
uh so to date there have been
seven cases
that we have confirmed
and
the cdc has requested of course at least
seven additional days out of an
abundance of caution to to pause these
flights that remains the case now we're
still assessing and working with the
national security team public health
officials and others to determine what
the next steps are here obviously it's
out of an abundance of caution and again
these individuals are being housed
separately in accordance with public
health guidelines but that's where we
stand at this point in time
with the september 18th rally this
weekend
i know karine was asked about this
yesterday but
should we expect should people in
washington dc expect to see any sort of
military presence national guard
presence you know in the city could you
give some details about just what to
expect security wise
from washington we are obviously always
watching and take steps in order to
ensure the security of people who work
in government we work closely with
congress on that we typically don't
predict that or lay that out in advance
and so i'm not going to do that from
here either go ahead
with only a couple weeks ahead of the
united nations climate summit obviously
the administration is still negotiating
a package right now that has climate at
its core do you all feel any pressure
right now to get this bill across the
line before the summit when you would
present to the world your ambitions on
climate change
well the summit is not for two months
so we have a bit of time and obviously
we certainly expect that it will move
forward in advance of that and then do
you all feel i guess in your
negotiations at the moment with senators
mansion and cinema for instance that
certain climate provisions may be
at stake um in the ongoing in the
current negotiations or that you might
have to downsize your ambitions there
specifically on climate well
i i would say first the the climate uh
components of the package are incredibly
important to the president and there are
some key components in the
infrastructure framework
which include
investments of course in rail increasing
public transit
ensuring that we have clean drinking
water across the country investment in
electric vehicles there are also key
components in the reconciliation package
providing tax cuts for businesses and
consumers who invest in clean energy
technologies sending a market signal
that brings additional private
investment off the sidelines and into
modernizing our electric grid mobilizing
the next generation of conservation and
resilience all of these pieces together
are vitally important to helping address
the climate crisis and moving our agenda
forward the president has still taken
additional steps
as he did uh just last month where he
announced steps to drive american
leadership forward on clean cars and
trucks aiming to grow good paying union
jobs at home and aligning with auto
makers and the united auto workers to
make half of all new vehicles sold in
the in 20 by 20 20 20 2030 excuse me
zero emissions so there are steps we can
take outside of these legislative pieces
but certainly moving these legislative
pieces forward will be significant the
president has advocated for them this is
an ongoing negotiation but he's made
clear they're important to him
go ahead
i'll go ahead
oh go ahead right in front of you yep go
ahead
thanks jen um you mentioned discussion
of mandates for international travel
does the president support mandates for
vaccine mayonnaise for domestic travel
we have not uh put in place uh
vaccine mandates for domestic travel
from the federal government no we have
not does he support that is it under
discussion has it been under discussion
at any point if not why not
well again there's always a range of
discussions about
additional steps that can be taken by
the federal government
to protect us all from covid to reduce
the spread
what we made the decision on our
determination on last week is that
putting in place these mandates and
requirements on businesses would have
the largest impact in helping reduce the
spread of covid protect more people and
save more lives so
we're maintaining existing travel
requirements at this point in time um
we're obviously continuing to discuss uh
a range of options as we always would be
good good for jessica okay can i go up
on that yes jeff science uh said today
though we are exploring considering
vaccination requirements for foreign
nationals traveling to the united states
that you're working now to be ready to
replace the current restrictions with a
new system for international travel uh
reading those words for him so what is
the time frame that you would imagine
for that are we talking about weeks here
are we talking about months before the
the holidays that are coming up what can
you tell us about that so i said
something similar in august um so did
jeff science about our desire to work
with through these working groups which
is different from the domestic question
this is about the international
component uh to create consistent uh
equitable approaches to that will also
keep the american people safe and keep
stop the spread of covet here i don't
have a projected timeline it's just an
ongoing discussion that's been on it's
been happening since last august
august sure and a separate question
about the the vaccine mandate that the
president yes does the president intend
for that to apply to employees of state
and local governments
state and local governments will make
decisions some of them have osha
requirements and laws and others don't i
mean we are still recommending
that
that states where they can uh mandate
vaccines obviously leaders will make
decisions on their own but it's really
state to state on whether it's
applicable under osha requirements
good thanks um on the biden sheet paul
can you clarify for us if president
biden asked president chief for a
meeting and president xi declined that i
think that's a little bit of confusion
sure well i know there's been some
reporting out there about this so let me
just reiterate a couple of things
president biden and president xi had a
broad strategic discussion uh the
question uh
as which you're asking about related to
a press report the president jake
sullivan both said it's not true that it
was not an accurate portrayal of the
call as we said at the time
they had a discussion about how to
continue the ongoing
channel of communication high level
channel of communication between the
presidents and that was certainly a part
of the discussion but in terms of what's
next or what format or what that looks
like uh any reports that suggest there
was a conclusion of that or inaccurate
so is it sorry is it inaccurate that the
request was made from the u.s president
to have a meeting or is it inaccurate
that the chinese president declined
because i think not true was not really
giving us the full picture of what in
the press reports is not accurate what's
accurate is there is an ongoing
discussion with the chinese leaders
about what net the next step should be
about engagement on a leader-to-leader
level but i don't have anything more to
preview for you at this point in time
one other issue
that i know is a big priority of yours
on the supply chain
specifically semiconductors
[Music]
what is your where in your priority list
is getting that broader china
competition bill through the congress
and how much can you give us a little
bit of context of how much your team is
working on that still how to get it done
when to get it done
well there's clearly a lot happening in
our legislative agenda right now but
you're absolutely right that moving this
forward is a priority it's part of the
discussion that senior members of the
white house have with leaders in
congress as we're talking about what we
want to get done in the in the coming
months i'm not going to give a rank
order obviously there's a number of
pieces we need to get done right now go
ahead karen thanks jen there was a new
poll from monmouth today that said that
found that two in 10 americans
don't think the country will ever go
back to normal after coping 19. what's
the white house message to americans who
are so pessimistic right now
our message is uh we understand your
frustration this has been a long haul
and we have all been
navigating through what has been a
difficult time in this country for
people across the country whether it's
because you have kids who are not yet
vaccinated whether because you're not
able to go to sporting events or go to
concerts or go out like you used to or
it's all difficult so first we would
acknowledge that but i would say the
second piece is that the president made
clear last week he's going to use every
lever possible from the federal
government to
reduce the spread of kovid to
save to protect more people to save more
lives that is what we will hope lead to
us going to back to a version of normal
the white house announced the president
will be going up to the un general
assembly can you give us a sense right
now what that day will look like is he
going to be holding bilateral meetings
and who might he be meeting with on the
sidelines sure i don't have anything
quite yet hopefully i'll have by
tomorrow um obviously he'll be giving
remarks while he's there he will have
some bilateral meetings hopefully we'll
have more on that in the next 24 or 40
hours or so go ahead patsy thanks jen so
on president biden's call to world
leaders to recommit
against the pandemic and the call to
fully vaccinate the world 70 of the
world population by next september
many experts that we've spoken to say
that this goal will be unlikely to be
achieved unless there is a vaccine
patent waiver at the wto the us has
supported this since may and it's been
months and it doesn't seem like
ambassador catherine ty has been able to
move the need a little bit so is the u.s
serious and would that be part of the
president's call in recommitting to the
fight against pandemic globally
well first i know there's been a range
of reports about an email invitation
that was sent out that was not an
announcement or determination of any
goals we're setting there's still a
discussion about that but i would say
that we always said from the beginning
the trip's waiver process would be a
long one it is i know we're in september
but we always knew that it would be a
lengthy process but that's never been
the only basket that we're focused on
we've also been focused on increasing
supply or vaccines supply to the world
where we provide more vaccines to the
world than any other country in the
world combined we've also been working
with countries on manufacturing capacity
and making sure they have the materials
they need so this is an across the board
approach it's not based on one
particular component but in terms of
specific
goals i know there's been some reports
about an invitation but those are not
yet determined represented from our
review on foreign policy the ukrainian
president's office issued a statement
that as part of the agreement reached
during the
biden and zelensky meeting
ukraine may receive new air and missile
defense systems in particular the iron
dome can you confirm
i'd have to check on that with our team
i know we announced we were providing
additional assistance
when we had that meeting but in terms of
the specifics i'd have to check with our
team go ahead um just a quick follow-up
on the timeline for the reconciliation
bill do you expect that to be signed
into law by the time haydn goes to
glasgow or just move forward
look i'm not really here to i'm not
setting a deadline on this all i'm
conveying is we're two months away is
what we're talking about with glasgow so
obviously we hope to make progress in
that period of time and we're certainly
making progress now but i wouldn't tie
it to what our meeting is there our
objectives our ability to achieve what
we want to do and then just one more on
on some of the the details of the plan
does the white house believe the fresh
taxes on cigarettes and vaping
violate gardens pledge not to tax
any americans that make less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year
uh no we don't um
uh but i'd also say that this is an idea
put forward there are a lot of a range
of ideas put forward this is the period
of the of the process where that
discussion is ongoing and the president
encouraged members of congress to put
things forward things they'd like to see
in the package uh revenue raisers that
they could see in the package but uh no
we don't believe that violates our
pledge
well i think our pledge one is related
to uh americans making less than four
hundred thousand dollars a year as their
income and their taxable income uh also
i know you're going to ask me probably
about
our opposition to the um vehicle mileage
tax uh millions of americans go to work
and
drive their cars and go to work uh and
and that would impact millions and
millions of americans obviously public
health guidance advises against smoking
so
that's not something that we think falls
into the same category but again it's
not an idea the president has proposed
um and it's just one that's been
proposed among many of memphis members
of congress
does the white house support that
proposal
it's not one we proposed um there are
negotiations they're happening now i'm
not going to negotiate all the
components from here but it wasn't one
that the president proposed in his
initial in his initial speech or
announcement but he's also encouraged
members to come forward with a range of
ideas
uh go ahead
thanks jen senators from both parties
have called for an investigation into
facebook's internal research on the way
uh young users uh young users are
affected by instagram
would the white house back these efforts
uh efforts by congress to investigate
facebook and their internal research on
instagram and how it affects young users
i did see some of the reporting i
haven't had a chance to really talk to
our team about this i would say that um
you know the president does think uh and
he has said that there are serious
issues around how much power internet
platforms have amassed in our society
and certainly some of that reporting as
an a is an example of that but in terms
of next steps i don't think i have a
further comment at this point in time
but i will see if there's more we have
to offer go ahead
thank you again a question about iran
iran has now a new chief nuclear
negotiator it's widely seen as a as a
sign that they are going to adopt a
tougher stance so does the president
still believe that he can restart the
folks with iran about mexico with us he
continues to believe that a diplomatic
path forward is the best path forward
and that
going back to a period of time where we
have visibility into iran's nuclear
capabilities that we can work with our
international partners
to hold them accountable is the best
step but obviously that is up to the
state department to determine what's
possible with diplomacy i know we have
to wrap here because i think you have to
go gather but why don't we do one last
one did the president watch any of the
emotional testimony from the u.s gymnast
earlier today i know you touched on his
message did he tune into any of it
i know he's had a full schedule today so
i'm not sure he's had the opportunity to
watch much of the testimony on
television we have mentioned it to him
because obviously it impacted many of us
as you're watching i don't know how
anyone couldn't have been impacted
watching it uh but i'm not sure if he'll
have an opportunity later today i know
he's been following this closely of
course still have confidence in his fbi
director given many of these young women
said they feel failed and betrayed by
the fbi one agent has been removed but
does the president believe that more
should be removed from their jobs if
they were involved there's an ig
investigation which is an important uh
process and one uh that should be
followed and the president certainly
supports that obviously the fbi director
was also testifying today and spoke to
his views of what went wrong here so i
point you to that okay thanks so much
everyone i think i gotta wrap because
you guys have to gather thanks everyone
and the arizona attorney general's soon
divided administration over the mandate
in-house pool please gather at the
stakeout location in-house pool please
gather at the stakeout location thank
you